un homme vient de tirer à l'intérieur
d'un centre de recrutement à Irkoutsk en
Sibérie la saillant est ensuite exhibée
par les forces de l'ordre c'est une des
nombreuses attaques contre ces lieux
symboliques de la mobilisation décrétée
par Vladimir Poutine à l'image de cet
autre centre à Orio Pinsk attaqua
avant-hier
tous les jours ou presque des Russes
protestent dans la rue comme ici dans le
nord-est du pays au risque de se faire
embarquer par la police voici tous les
lieux où des manifestations ont eu lieu
en Russie depuis jeudi dernier
et là toutes les attaques recensées
contre les bâtiments administratifs une
contestation sans précédent
on est bien loin de la mobilisation
rêvée par le Kremlin à l'image de ces
vidéos diffusées par le ministère de la
Défense ou tout se passe en bon ordre ou
déprime son promises au soldat et ou des
naturalisations sont offertes aux
étrangers qui s'engagent pour la Russie
voici ce qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux diffusés par un média interdit
en Russie on y voit des soldats entassés
dans des baraquements
vous avez des sacs de couchage pour nous
non c'est vous qui les amenez nous
allons vous donner des
uniformes
c'est des vidéos qui s'ajoutent à celles
de cet exode massif aux frontières du
pays notamment vers la Géorgie des
kilomètres de bouchons des hommes qui ne
veulent pas faire la guerre
à Moscou certains aux exprimés leur
exaspération les militaires entoure
ratés
c'est complet dans le pays
tous les secteurs d'activité et dans
l'armée on voit bien que le système ne
fonctionne pas du tout tout est à
l'abandon embarrassé acculé après cette
semaine cauchemardesque le Kremlin a
reconnu hier des erreurs dans cette
mobilisation militaire les imputants à
l'administration